على مدار نحو 18 عاما هو طبعا عمره صباح
العربيه احنا من عمره تقريبا
استضافت او استضاف البرنامج شخصيات مرموقه
عربيه وعالميه تنوعت ما بين الفن الرياضه
الصحه والاعلام التقى بهم في الاستوديو
وخارجه ومن وسط ارشيفه الغني اخترنا لكم
بعضا من هذه المقابلات
باقي على حاله ما يقارب من العشرين عاما
وصباح العربيه يواكب الاحداث والفعاليات
العربيه والعالميه فهناك فنانون عالميون
مروا في مشوارنا الصباحي
مارتن وستنج
وماريا كاروي وجنيفر لوبيز وليال ومنهم من
فارقنا كوارث الجزائريه التي اجرت اخر
لقاءاتها في صباح العربيه قبل ان ترحل
ومنهم من ترك بصمه قد تكون ابديه في عالم
الغناء والموسيقى كبيبي كينج وشعر اذنبوه
وملحم بركات واخرون كثر كانوا وما زالوا
اصدقاء البرنامج يوافينه بكل جديد
اصداراتهم وحفلاتهم حول العالم
القيصر او كاظم الساهر ونانسي عجرم والشاب
خالد وغيرهم الكثير
[موسيقى]
صباح العربيه كان وما زال سباقا في مجالات
عده ففي عالم الازياء والموضه كان اول
برنامج تلفزيوني صباحي يواكب عروض الازياء
الرجاليه العالميه من باريس وعواصم الموضه
الاوروبيه اما السينما فكانت حاضره بقوه
في صباح العربيه ضمن لقاءات حصريه مع
نجومها يسرى وحسين فهمي
ووردون وجيمس كام وكيني
ومنهم من فارقنا كالامريكي
الذي توفي في منزله في مدينتي نيويورك
صباح العربيه
بيسعدني كتير لانه ياما بحفلاتي بشوف
اشخاص
يعني مثل ما بقولوا على هيفا بنبسط انه
فيها هاللوك
الطاغي على البنات والسيدات بسببي
كيف تحكمين على الكتاب الذي تختارينه
للقراءه تقرئين بضعه صفحات ومن ثم ان تمكن
منك هذا الكتاب تكملينه بالكامل
بدون انترنت وبدون تكنولوجيا اخذت معي
جوال اللي هو يسموه
وديت رقمه زوجتي ولابويا والمديره الشركه
عندي قلت لهم لا احد يكلمني الا اذا في دم
انا دايما بقول الشباب
يعني مفيش جوائز وما فيش حاجه بتدي
السعاده قد
الشفاء مريض او
اكتشاف حاجه جديده
صراحه يعني محمد ودينا فعلا صباح العربيه
تحسها مدرسه ان كان من نوعيه الحوارات
واللقاءات يعني من فنانين لاعب كره قدم
مغنيين مطربين كتاب
يعني ذكريات حلوه